welcome back to las vegas now easter is
on sunday can you believe it and while
the kids are hunting down their easter
eggs the parents can enjoy some wine and
cheese pairings to go with all the you
know the easter treats that are lying
around so you know what that means let's
welcome back diana breer briar
oh my gosh i can't spell briar without
brie it's okay yeah burger would be so
divine the wonder woman of cheese and
owner of valley wine and cheese i guess
we were talking about this before this
segment you know i'm not a huge fan of
easter candy right especially peeps so
if you can change my mind with with
cheese and wine to go with it i'm here
for it so one of the things that i
always say is that like regardless of
how you celebrate easter
um candy's going to be involved right
and as the parents or the adult figures
in the situation it might be too much of
a sugar bomb for our more advanced
palace absolutely so what we're going to
do is we're going to take those down a
notch and make them more adult friendly
by adding some wine and some cheese
obviously
let's start with some jelly beans so
jelly beans are kind of a staple in in
easter so grab a few jelly beans there
go ahead and chew them up you and a few
at once okay once yeah like a purple
yellow whatever i got purple pink and
white perfect so you're going to chew
those up a little bit you notice that's
just that classic sort of sugar bomb add
a semi-sweet riesling onto your palette
right now okay and that is how
well because you don't want an overly
sweet we actually tried this pairing
with moscato and it was just a sugar
bomb
so when you add a semi-sweet riesling
it's going to highlight some of the
natural stone fruit characteristics and
the wine take down that sugariness of
the jelly bean a little bit and it
really is very playful and tropical and
it's got a little sparkle to it so it
helps too yeah so that's sugar and the
natural sort of effervescence is trapped
from that co2 in the bottle that's going
to be beautiful i mean it's not a
sparkling wine it's a riesling but it is
going to have a little bit of that high
acidity that just a little taste makes
it pop a little bit so that's our first
way to sort of get through jelly beans i
can do that okay let's get through peeps
because these i always tell people like
i really am not a snacker on peeps
typically um but let's see what happens
so go ahead and grab whoever your victim
is
and
take a quick bite because they know this
one's too
take a quick bite and then chew around a
little bit we actually added the only
rose of port in the world so this is a
rose port it's very like it's very
friendly very floral a little bit sweet
nice strawberry notes go ahead and add a
little bit of that port onto the palette
wait i'm sorry i finished it do i need
to have it yeah i have a little bit
chewing around yeah i know it's not your
favorite thing in the world but it
should change your mind once you add the
port port is a fortified wine so it has
a lot of sweetness what happens there is
it actually blows right through the
marshmallow and just punches all those
notes onto the palette yeah that
completely just it eliminates the peep
for me yes and so i should just like use
the peep as a delivery vehicle or like a
canvas upon which the port can paint all
of those beautiful flavor profiles you
are a poet girl okay sometimes we've got
a little less than a minute okay so
perfect the next one is our show stopper
so this is a cadbury cream egg and this
is a smoked goat's milk cheese from the
canary islands of spain actually when
you stick i'm gonna have you take like a
hero bite here when you stick this
cheese into this egg go ahead and take
it
just go for it i mean it's not going to
be the cutest thing we've ever seen but
it is one of the best pairings because
it's going to turn that cadbury cream
egg into a s'more on the palette oh my
god
wow
you just took that candy and made it
like
glorious
yeah so we love to do that because i
think that if any pairing is a cheese
pairing if you try hard and believe in
yourself
and